okay today I'm going to talk to you
about sti's STI just stands for sexually
transmitted infections now for the GCSE
there's two different sti's we need to
know about HIV and chlamydia now
chlamydia has got a very difficult
spelling like this so all I'm gonna do
is go through each one to tell you a
little bit about each one so HIV the V
gives us a clue that it is in fact a
virus so we remember all the viruses is
very simple structure it has a protein
coats around the outside and in the
middle it has genetic material so that
could either be DNA or RNA so what a
virus needs to do in order to reproduce
is it needs to infect a host cell so it
can't reproduce by itself it needs to go
inside another cell so these cells that
it attacks in in humans is of white
blood cells so it needs to attack this
and by doing so it actually kills white
blood cells now this is a big problem
because white blood cells help to fight
against other pathogens so if one of our
white blood cells are wiped out it means
we're very vulnerable to get ill from
other pathogens so what's the
relationship between HIV and AIDS now
I'm going to draw this little graph that
will help us visualize it so what this
shows is the number of white blood cells
over time so HIV is the virus which
kills white blood cells and over time
those numbers of white blood cells are
going to come down and down and down
what AIDS is is after a while we get
AIDS as a result of HIV so HIV is the
virus AIDS is the disease that were it
will eventually cause because all AIDS
is is when we get below a certain number
of white blood cells your body is
extremely vulnerable to other pathogens
and even the car even a flu influenza or
something like this can suddenly become
threatening so how is it spread
essentially HIV is spread in bodily
fluids such as blood semen and vaginal
fluids so obviously it could be it can
be spread through sexual intercourse it
can't be spread through saliva and
kissing now how do we make sure that
we've someone can help to kind of
protect themselves against the spread of
HIV so the key ones is first of all wear
a condom during sex because remember it
could be spread in semen or vaginal
fluids make sure well sometimes
intravenous drug users share their
needles and therefore they're
transferring blood from one person to
another so needles is another way that
is spread also the screening process is
very important it's important for people
to have go to sexual health clinics to
make sure they don't have this disease
so they don't pass it on to other people
they can people with HIV can take
medicine to make sure they don't pass it
on to someone else
okay chlamydia now chlamydia is a little
bit different from HIV it's less
life-threatening in fact it's not
life-threatening at all now instead of
being transported transferred by a virus
the pathogen involved this time is a
back tears bacteria now similarly though
to HIV chlamydia virus sorry chlamydia
bacterium needs a host in order for it
to reproduce now strangely enough quite
often chlamydia does not have any
symptoms this means there's no outward
sign to show that you've got chlamydia
so what's the problem
well the problem is it can actually
cause infertility in both men and women
now infertility is when you're unable to
have a baby so you can see it's very
important to be able to find out if
you've got chlamydia so you can take the
right antibiotics to get rid of those
bacteria otherwise you could become
infertile so how can we stop it from
spreading again use a condom during
sexual intercourse
this is a very good mechanism to make
sure the bodily fluids are not being
shared screening process again it's
important to go to a sexual health
clinic because if you've got chlamydia
it's quite easy to get rid of it with
some antibiotics but you need to know
that you've got it because it's
symptomless
and also another option I guess in both
of them
is avoiding sexual contact altogether so
just to summarize HIV life-threatening
caused by a virus and it attacks white
blood cells it leads to AIDS the midea
caused by a bacterium is symptomless and
leads to infertility both of them are
sexually transmitted infections known as
sti's thank you